[Applaudissements]
2010cette année de la consécration pour
le plaisir handball club après avoir
lutté pour la montée pendant six ans les
plaisirs aux accède enfin à la nationale
je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits enfin c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une grande
famille c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les nous c'est vraiment un un club qui
avec lui ce moment là tous ensemble
après l'euphorie retour sur terre
plaisir se mesurer pour la première fois
une équipe de nationale 3 en coupe de
france début septembre après un match
serré les plaisirs oies sont finalement
éliminé par le club d'ici aux tirs au
but le score 28 à 27 une défaite
formatrice pour le groupe une équipe est
réellement profil des équipes de
nationale 3 à savoir des joueurs avec un
petit peu tous les profils et notamment
des grands gabarits qui sont capables
d'aller jouer des duels et ces choses
qu'on trouve très peu en prénationale
donc voila c'était très intéressant de
jeu cette équipe avec voilà nos qualités
après quatre mois de compétition plaisir
pointe à la deuxième place du
championnat de nationale 3 à trois
longueurs du leader saint polois les
yvelines ont notamment réalisé une série
de quatre victoires consécutives entre
octobre et novembre
l'équipe a été remaniée puisque
effectivement on a perdu quelques
joueurs
le fait d'avoir pris ces quelques
joueurs n'ont pas changé l'état d'esprit
du groupe
l'état d'esprit est toujours positif les
mecs s'entraîne sérieusement on
s'entraîne sérieusement et donc cette
deuxième place au championnat je pense
qu'elle est méritée
maintenant on sait que ça va être dur de
la garder ma nounou battre et continuer
sur cet état d'esprit qui est pour
l'instant est repproché avec cette bande
de potes à l'animé plaisir ne sourit
plus les plaisirs wa concèdent leur
troisième défaite en quatre matchs
contre l'entente pcn le score est sévère
33 à 24 plaisir redescend à la quatrième
place
les barrages s'éloigne pour plaisir et
l'équipe enregistre de nombreux blessés
le dispositif qu on a line sont pas les
dispositifs qu'on aligne habituellement
donc forcément on essaye de trouver des
solutions là où finalement il n'a
peut-être pas et voilà mais bon c'est
juste parce qu'on essaye de rester
compétiteurs jusqu'au bout et de se
battre avec nos armes quoi plaisir
s'accroche dans le sprint final et
enregistre deux victoires et un match
nul pour terminer deuxième et arraché
des barrages les plaisirs wa s'incline
finalement contre molsheim sur terrain
neutre 27 à 26 et voient leurs espoirs
de montée s'envoler en c'est trop je
hais
arrivé au match de barrage on ya
vraiment cru et sur le terrain on ya cru
parce qu'on a vraiment dominé cette
équipe de molsheim et malheureusement
sur soi le money time
ça tombe pas en notre faveur pour sa
première année en nationale 3 plaisir a
été l'équipe surprise et sera la
formation à suivre pour la montée la
saison prochaine
[Musique]